chez lyon au carbure l'électricité
l'entreprise de saint jérôme qui établit
des autobus scolaires électrique est en
pleine croissance
on doit agrandir les installations on
est passé de quelques employés en 2008
au dessus de 250 cette année et on va
probablement doubler le à l'intérieur
des deux prochaines années
châssis batterie fourgon l'autobus cette
assemblée de a à z dans les
installations d'entreprises savoir faire
québécois qui s'est fait remarqué aux
états unis l'été dernier lyon a décroché
le plus gros contrat de son histoire
pour la vente de 200 autobus en
californie bientôt on va annoncer des
commandes encore beaucoup plus
importante que celle qu'ont annoncé dans
l'autobus scolaire donc l'autobus
scolaire continue sa progression mais le
camion électrique est après prendre sa
place et va donner un important
l'important produits pour nouveau dans
les prochaines semaines la compagnie a
mis au point un camion 10 roues
entièrement électrique lit on va aussi
développer des véhicules spécialisés
comme des camions nacelles de collecte
des ordures et des ambulances en
partenariat avec d'autres entreprises
lycos comme québécois avec plusieurs de
ses partenaires là on est à peine créée
il ya tout une opportunité de prendre
une place de leader dans le monde six
mille emplois 147 entreprises des ventes
de plus de 2 milliards de dollars par
année
l'industrie du transport électrique et
intelligent est en pleine effervescence
au québec
en plus des véhicules lourds on fabrique
des batteries des bornes de recharge des
logiciels et des capteurs pour le
véhicule autonome
un secteur porteur mais qui est freiné
par le manque de main d'oeuvre
j'ai une tonne d'entreprise qui me
disent je ne sais pas comment je vais
faire pour sortir toutes mes commandes
dans les prochains mois j'ai passé plus
tard si vous pouviez embaucher des
travailleurs
on embauche auriez convient que dans un
monde idéal une quarantaine d'ingénieurs
demain matin et une cinquantaine de
personnes sur la ligne de production
mais les défis de recrutement ne stoppe
pas les ambitions de marc bédard d'ici
dix ans il veut que lyon domine le
marché de l'autobus et du camion
électrique en amérique du nord et
peut-être même ailleurs ici olivier
bâche un réseau canada
saint girons